we go long way back we do uh hung on oh
wow you fixing your hair i like that oh
my god you are so distracted i know i'm
so distracted yeah look at you
you know what you're gonna we're gonna
end this interview and you're gonna look
at me i'm taking my glasses off i don't
want you why'd
look at me i just took my glasses off
look at me and deal with me i'm right
here it's not about them it's about you
and me
you and me
when we retire from comedy
we're gonna live together
you you wouldn't yeah you want to do
that i want to do that do you want to
live without it done the two of us
together in an apartment i want it done
but then you're probably gonna go after
my walmart money well i'd like a piece
of
it man
i'm not sharing that with no one
okay but
conan yeah
what was i gonna say just now before you
distracted me you were gonna say conan
you're the best you're the funniest and
i love you more than i've ever loved
anyone else in this world absolutely you
said it just like i wrote it absolutely
tracy i love you i really do love you
more conan
you know what the best thing about me
and you what we're always going to be
friends being with you you taught me a
lot and i was comfortable because you
were a writer on snl
so you came you are literally my alumni
that's true
literally it's like we were in the army
together at different times but yeah i
think everyone at snl i knew what the
drill was yeah i'm happy to be here now
all right i'm going to hang out with you
for the rest of the day what are we
doing just hanging okay whatever we go
to times square we just hang out i don't
want to go to town well my boy runs the
big apple circus we can go over there
and watch him walk through a high wire
you know it doesn't matter i think
people get creeped out if you and i are
hanging out on the big apple circus all
right we could go to benihanas oh i love
benihanas i know benny i went to high
school with benny
did you teach him to light stuff on fire
was that you that was me choo-choo train
and all that yeah i
gave him that turn all right
tracy morgan i'm gonna um i hate to let
you go but i gotta let you go because i
don't have other things to do but uh
i'll be back as long as you're doing
this i'll be back i will talk to you and
i have a lot of stuff to talk about and
you know i'll tell you i will talk to
you anytime i will learn very little
most of what you say is not true
but uh you also but you don't talk to
everybody no i don't you just don't i
don't and everybody ain't doing this
show no
you're a good man we're shaking hands
right now i love you conan i love you
too man